we call on the government to immediately
and unconditionally release these
journalists and these human rights
defenders there were upcoming elections
in 2020 an important point for the
country I welcome the fact that
president Pierre in Cruiser has said he
will not seek re-election but in order
for there to be credible elections major
changes considerable improvements to the
political and human rights situation are
needed record I know for me more she had
more led to media station a betrayer
who's applied Libya has shown immediate
a journalist do a coup in the to
personally sony bravia x-axis on what la
libertad expression i finally we take
the situation is Santos if he not a hero
with applause silly new African on
voices Observateur of the doís Zuma
booboo hoondi in with a prole UN
announced it is not yet impartial surely
person suspected of Arkham individualís
wounded waddlin es necesaria la
libération in media tan conditioner de
todos los detenidos case press on Libre
meant a sus opinions else si in media
toda la violencia be Latinas derechos
humanos real intimidation política
Conrado gia civil y la posición actual
de manera de FEV de en favor de la
libertad expression a lavaliere las
medidas adopted as contra on SS y medio
de comunicación respite are lost Rados
Internacional esto sobre su manos yone
Rada tortora
via listened in hook off the whole
understand Bearden I'll fix the height
in this week musty Internet's with Alec
Mannschaft stock so some steam one daft
isn't work niched
hunt on him wouldn't the bonus in be
heard and with some empty stuff is organ
that's the mention register after the
beardless book is a stochastic baton
that's fire - also moon nucleus one
that's in my disney Ava's
fry a vine in Anna didn't democratic
stepped in there are signs that tensions
could increase further in the run-up to
elections that are now foreseen 420 ma
vie relations and abuses of human rights
and fundamental freedoms in particular
freedom of expression
freedom of assembly and freedom of
association persist across the country a
case of four journalists imprisoned
journalists of the avato was mentioned
by many here and I would like to assure
that the EU is keeping this issue very
high on its agenda with the authorities
Europe must continue to support the
people of Nigeria and promote the
regional cooperation encourage further
reforms like for security and in the
army our determination and efforts to
end religious and sectarian violence and
to protect women in the region must
never waver so we can stop the poisonous
and destructive spread of terror
organizations haven't even thought of
whooping Borden boo mention kind of
perspex even vena cava and here on harm
old his organs of climate on the lights
can be a trespasser that's why it's hard
for all to heaven except ask a few on
this globerman Kaunas unsigned oil-rich
Mohandas one giant icons politic for art
to off Alphonse van egmond interesting
characters unleash own bidding new
funding and haryana some prefer Co
tenemos que si here Crespin Salida a
nuestras Empress's por las relaciones de
derechos humanos
la s trophy own del medio ambiente ahora
qué tanto habla Mo's en este parlamento
del new Rindell no podemos Eskander quel
Delta del near Sol erogenous mess
contaminated el mundo
gracias a large multinational s Thaman
europaeus the EU continues to stand
ready to assist Nigeria in responding to
its security humanitarian and
development crisis in particular around
Lake Chad but also in the Northwest
Middle Belt niger delta and elsewhere
and in all these cases a comprehensive
approach that addresses the root causes
is necessary in our view